In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadium for June 15th, on which we commemorate the Holy Prophet
Amos.
The Holy Prophet Amos was a simple herdsman and sikamore grower in the village of Tecoa
a few miles from Bethlehem in the kingdom of Judah.
He lived during the reigns of Uzziah, King of Judah, from 781 through 740, and Jeroboam
II, King of Israel, 784 through 744.
While he was keeping his flock, the Lord called him and said to him, Go and prophesy to
my people, Israel.
He went to the northern kingdom which was then at its apogee, but in which the rich were
scandalously oppressing the poor, living disillute lives, and having abandoned the worship
of the living God to bow down before the golden calf.
Because of this, God ordered his prophet to proclaim to them that their punishment was imminent.
Amos first predicted the ruin of the neighboring pagan nations.
Damascus, Felistia, Phoenicia, Edom, Ammon, and Moab, and added that the Lord's wrath would
also fall on the kingdom of Judah.
And before that, on the kingdom of Samaria, that had profaned his holy name with their
idol worship.
The prophet had a vision of a multitude of locusts that devoured all Israel's crops, but
he interceded for the people, and the plague was averted.
Then God showed him that he was preparing to chastise with fire, but once more, the prophet's
prayers calmed the Lord's wrath.
The inhabitants of the northern kingdom in no way repented and persisted in their sin, so
the Lord showed his prophet in three visions that he would forgive no longer, and that he
would strike the rebellious and swoop down on their proud cities.
Against those who boasted of being the chosen people and prided themselves on God's favor,
he said, the day of the Lord that they were awaiting would be darkness and not light.
Their hypocritical worship, mixed with iniquity, had drawn the Lord's anger on them, and
he rejected them, saying, I hate, I despise your feast days, and I will not support your
solemn assemblies.
Take thou away from me the noise of thy songs, for I will not hear the melody of thy vials.
The punishment of their pride would be terrible, corpses would be flung down indiscriminately
in all places, and all who did not perish would be in lamentation and mourning.
These catastrophes would mark the definitive end of the schismatic kingdom of Israel.
The Virgin of Israel is fallen, she shall no more rise.
She also proclaim from afar the cosmic upheavals at the end of time.
Despite these predictions of calamity, not all hope of salvation would be lost to those
who were converted.
Seek the Lord that ye may live, hate the evil, and love the good, and establish judgment
in the gate.
It may be that the Lord of hosts will be gracious unto the remnant of Joseph.
For then, says the Lord, I will send a famine in the land, not a famine of bread or a thirst
or water, but of hearing the words of the Lord.
When the prophet spoke the oracles to Bethel, the priest Amazaya accused him before the king
of fomenting a conspiracy in proclaiming that the sovereign would perish by the sword,
and that the people would be carried off far from their land.
He said to Amazaya, O thou seer, flee thee away into the land of Judah, and there eat bread
and prophesy there, but prophesy not again anymore at Bethel.
For it is the king's chapel, and it is the king's court.
He is, however, persisted in his mission, and foretold to the priest that he would die
in exile.
He continued to glorify God, who would reveal his glory through judgment and the extermination
of sinners.
But he made it clear in ending his prophecy that these disasters would notwithstanding end
the restoration of the line of David and the establishment of the Messianic kingdom, towards
which all the pagan nations were hastening.
After this I will return, and will build again the tabernacle of David which has fallen down,
and I will set it up that the residue of men might seek after the Lord, and all the Gentiles
upon whom my name is called, sayeth the Lord, who doeth all these things.
Known unto God are all his works from the beginning of the world.
In those days, added the prophet, the mountains shall drop sweet wine, and all the earth will
be transformed into a garden of everlasting fruits.
A later tradition tells us that Hosea, son of Amaziah, struck Amos a blow with a club,
leaving him half dead.
The prophet was then taken to his own land, Takawa, where he died a few days later.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.